Volyn
[Ukraїner
The Expedition]
[Ostroh Academy
Ostroh]
The first higher educational institution in Eastern Europe and the oldest scientific and educational institution in Ukraine.
[Sculptor’s house
Lutsk]
The house and workshop of the sculptor Mykola Holovan, decorated with 500 of his original sculptures.
[The Tunnel of Love
Klevan]
A green corridor formed by trees stretching along the railway line.
[The Historical and Cultural Preserve "Samchyky"
Samchyky]
Thanks to the collective efforts of the local community, a palace and the traditional Samchyky painting technique were preserved.
[The Monastery of the Barefoot Carmelites
Berdychiv]
One of the most famous Baroque buildings in Ukraine.
[Fisherman’s house
Staryi Solotvyn]
The picturesque fisherman's house is located on an island in the middle of the Kodnianka river.
[Luge track
Kremenets]
The only bobsleigh track in Ukraine. The first track at this place was built in the 19th century.
[Lubart’s Castle
Lutsk]
Lutsk Castle is one of the largest, best preserved and oldest castles in Ukraine.
[Tarakaniv Fort
Tarakaniv]
A defence construction from the 19th century built near the town of Dubno to protect the Lviv-Kyiv railway line.
[Cameramen:
Pavlo Pashko, Oleh Solohub]
[Director:
Mykola Nosok]
[Music:
Tik Tu]
[Ukraїner
The Expedition]